[Music]  your daddy died in the ring I'll know  him  [Music]  we like a cousin he's my father  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh I don't hate bellboy but I pity the  fool  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  whatever he is he destroyed our country  Apollo Creed is well known and very  respected it could be a good victory  whoa  [Applause]  how good wasn't oh yeah it was great  ain't nobody ever better  I was afraid I couldn't live up to these  expectations  Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who  infamously killed Apollo Creed appeared  today to issue a challenge to Adonis  Creed that kid was raised in hate I want  you to train me  I think isn't slowing down  [Music]  this guy's got nothing to loose ain't  got a choice let's just say that your  father said he died right here in my  hair your [ __ ] I'm stopping this one now  rewrite history this is more than just  fight I stepped in Henry  [Applause]  [Music]